I'm Laura Ingram this is Ingram angle
from Washington tonight well I'm a
former White Collar criminal defense
lawyer might not have known that about
me and I read the entire 16-page
indictment handed down by left-wing New
York D.A Alvin Bragg and here's my
reaction
just another political hit job under New
York state law is a felony
to falsify business records with intent
to the fraud and an intent to conceal
another crime
that is exactly what this case is about
well a blatantly false statement here's
the only thing non-lawyers need to know
about this case
if after the 2020 election Donald Trump
had announced that he was retiring from
politics Alvin Bragg would not have
indicted him or let's say if after 2020
Trump had gradually evolved in his views
and maybe became more like Romney or one
of the bushes
in that case Alvin Bragg would not have
indicted him
the real reason that Donald Trump was
booked and fingerprinted today comes
down to one simple fact
he has the wrong political views
now to the entire class of politicians
and media figures who cheered the
proceedings today Donald Trump
represents an existential threat a
threat to the regime that's run our
country into the ground for decades a
threat to the credibility of the media
that he calls out relentlessly
but most significant of all
another Trump term is a threat to the
Biden family and their non-stop Griff
machine
even Bragg is more like Alvin bagg
because he's Nothing But The Bag Man for
the White House hoping his reward comes
when he runs for let's say Governor as
the Trump Slayer
yeah right now he's just the middleman
for the DNC and an illicit scheme to
interfere in the 2024 election cycle
and his astonishingly thin indictment
brag alleges that it was Trump who may
have now I say may have attempted to
interfere in the 2020 election or may
have violated state election laws by
allegedly ordering that former
Mistresses be paid off then concealing
the reimbursement of those payouts now
in a few moments we're going to be
talking with a former chair of the
Federal Election Commission who'll
explain why the FEC decided against
pursuing the case on similar grounds
but as we suspected last week the
question Bragg left everyone asking
today is where's the beef
here's where we're going to run into
legal problems because the indictment
does not say what that second crime is
which is completely inexplicable to me
the entire point of an indictment is to
tell the defendant here's what you're
charged with but he said Federal
campaign election law but this is New
York state so he said state election law
but this is a campaign for president
which is a federal office and there's
literally one word about this in the
statement effect said something about
tax but they didn't take a deduction of
real questions about this it's
disappointment it's hard to imagine
convincing a jury that that they should
get there one source said to me this is
Donald Trump you don't bring a knife to
a gunfight I had hoped that there would
be more in the indictment
translation this case is a dead dog in
the middle of the road have someone come
pick it up and give it a prompt burial
but the portly D.A tried to sell his
case today and inadvertently engaged in
some stand-up comedy these are felony
crimes in New York state
no matter who you are
we cannot and will not normalize serious
criminal conduct what normalizing
serious criminal conduct is all his
office it ever does like the case from
over the weekend where a parking garage
attendant saw a man casing the cars in
his garage he confronted the suspect who
then pulled out a handgun and shot the
parking attendant twice the worker of
Musa diaria wrestled the gun away and
shot the suspect in the chest
now in the real world where I tend to
live the worker did the right thing but
in the brag world the parking attendant
was charged with attempted murder along
with the actual criminal this is insane
Bragg finally backtracked and announced
only after public outcry that he would
not prosecute diary but you know he
would have if he could have the damage
has already been done
but you really really know this case
against Trump is like a leaky roof when
even Mitt Romney throws shade at Bragg
Romney's saying that Bragg is trying to
fit a political agenda and his overreach
sets a dangerous precedent for
criminalizing political opponents
well the one good thing that may come
out of this dark chapter though for
America will be what I want to just dub
tonight as state brag laws where State
legislatures decide to disincentivize
State DA's or state AGS from using their
positions as batting battering rams
against individuals and corporations
simply to feather their own political
resumes
these laws would bar the state AGS of
the DA's from running for governor let's
say for at least 10 years or maybe ever
the history of New York alone where
hyper political prosecutors use their
office to try to advance their political
careers
if prostitution Scandal if that hadn't
derailed them former State prosecutor
turned governor Elliot Spitzer might
have made it too they were talking about
him as president in 2004 the Elite's
favorite magazine the Atlantic Doug
Spitzer the Crusader and proclaimed that
he was the future of the Democrat Party
Heaven Help Us
the bottom line is this Brad sprag Saga
is yet another urgent warning that we
must have a federal criminal justice
system that Americans of all political
backgrounds will trust trust to do what
is right
not one that will deliver political
dividends either for his party or for
him personally
our justice system at every level should
be the Envy of the world not a laughing
stock hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else